[Musique]
une nouvelle mode chez les jeunes la
tecktonik cette danse très spectaculaire
a vu jour dans une boîte de nuit à
réagissent elle s'est propagé grâce à
internet les jeunes film leurs
performances pour les diffuser sur la
toile
à paris les adeptes au rendez vous aux
halles et au trocadéro regardez le
reportage d'alexandra lequel et norbert
cohen
c'est une première une aprem électro
organisée dans la plus mythique des
salles de musique à paris l'olympia
transformé pour l'occasion en
gigantesque piste de danse une danse
singulière que des milliers de jeunes
ont adopté ces derniers mois
la tectonique un peu partout dans paris
le phénomène s'étend au trocadéro alex
14 ans on retrouve chaque samedi ses
amis ils dansent depuis quatre mois
c'est ma soeur les rangs cette boîte
elle m'a dit bâtir une prudence en boîte
et elle m'a montré des vidéos sur
internet et c'est comme ça que j'ai
appris que j'ai connu la cadence ya de
la brèque des ponts il ya du mouvement
ils ont vraiment rêvé on va dire il ya
plein de mouvements il ya du fait de
leur petit goût et à jack ça et
d'électro
quatre ans il y en a plein c'est varié
ce qui a donné à cette danse la
tecktonik est apparue au métropolis il
ya sept ans un concept de soirée de
musique électronique importé de belgique
lancé par cette boîte de nuit de rungis
aujourd'hui la tectonique et sorties des
pistes de danse et c'est toute une
partie de la jeunesse de 13 à 20 ans qui
se reconnaît dans ce mouvement
il a son code vestimentaire tee shirt au
logo fluo personnalisé et une coupe de
cheveux réglementaire la plus demandée
depuis un an dans ce salon branché la
crème avec un dégradé de vent est assez
court sur les côtés pour voyez bien a
créé par semaine
depuis pas mal de temps je note aussi si
c'est ça l'est devenu en france le
phénomène touche aujourd'hui la france
entière un engouement massif relayées
par internet
la plupart des jeunes filment leurs
exploits avant de les mettre en ligne
connaissez-vous le mot tectoniques
si vous ne connaissez pas vous allez
découvrir une danse qui fait fureur chez
certains ados de la région parisienne
une danse popularisés par internet un
phénomène né dans les clubs
résultat aujourd'hui on danse tecktonik
mais on s'habille aussi tectoniques une
opération marketing qui peut rapporter
gros reportage de feurat dendoune et
michel anglade un déhanché à la travolta
des bras qui moulinent non-stop un jeu
de jambes à faire pâlir de jalousie un
boxeur professionnel et de l'énergie à
revendre voilà les ingrédients de la
tecktonik
beaucoup de bouteilles vos potes ans
c'est l'ambiance et le métro pas
[Musique]
merci
moi je suis militaire
nous sommes en banlieue parisienne dans
l'un des temples de la musique
électronique
cinq salles de danse pleine à craquer et
des mim et de tecktonik killers comme il
se surnomme moyenne d'âge 18 ans c'est
ici qu'il ya sept ans le patron a
importé le phénomène d'angleterre un
mélange de house et de techno dont il a
su faire une marque à part entière
soirée techno est basé principalement
sur tout ce qui était musique techno
ensuite il ya eu une certaine évolution
dans le style musical puisque on s'est
rendu compte que les clients sont là
c'est un petit peu donc on a dérivé sur
des nouvelles musiques comme l'électro
la house et le business fonctionne ici
tout est frappée à l'effigié de l'aigle
le logo de la marque on danse on
s'habille et on boit tectoniques
[Musique]
comme pour les combats de boxe un ring
sur lequel on s'approche jeux de
lumières grosse on est fan hystérique
les vainqueurs sont désignés à
l'applaudimètre
le mouvement a aussi son dress code
tétine piercing fluo et brassards
indispensable ce marketing n'est pas au
goût de tous ces jeunes ont été les
premiers à diffuser cette danse sur
internet depuis chaque mois ils
investissent les rues de paris et refuse
d'être récupéré des vêtements des abîmes
des soirées vous appelez ça comment la
danse et la musique électro donc des
gens mais aussi dans leur panoplie
ils créent eux mêmes leurs t-shirts avec
leur propre logo rien de porter la pétro
voilà comme tout le monde en fait non
non vous des corps en silence
différencie des gens comme le hip hop en
son temps la danse électro a conquis la
planète ado phénomène de mode ou
mouvement durable elle s'exporte peu à
peu dans les villes de province sentant
le bon filon les salles de sport
branchés vont même proposé des cours dès
la rentrée
[Musique]